how can you trick Google and become a
celebrity the criteria for a person's
popularity in Google is a kind of
knowledge panel where basic information
about a person is collected but not many
people know that this panel can be
created independently for example just a
normal guy from India Savannah is
according to google a musician blogger
and even an actor his method is simple
step one spam information about yourself
on all sites where users can add and
edit information themselves
step two write your name in the credits
of films on the Internet Movie Database
next create several music remixes using
other people's tracks and upload them to
various platforms now you just need to
wait a little bit result Google will
collect this information about you from
open sources and create a knowledge
panel turning any ordinary person into a
celebrity subscribe to our Channel and
remember not to believe everything you
read on the internet